I think what our friends and partners
want is a Britain that's confident that
works with them to address some of the
really tough issues and here in in New
York actually there's a very difficult
issue how do you respond to what the
Iranians plainly did in blowing up those
of those Saudi Arabian oil fields and
there are some people who want to be
very tough others who can see real
difficulties are going down that track
so what the UK is doing is trying to
bring people together trying to
deescalate tensions come up with a
solution
for the Gulf region my own view very
strong is whatever your objections to
the old nuclear deal with Iran it's time
now to move forward and do a new deal
and so we'll be working with our
European friends and with the Americans
to try and encourage that way of
thinking but this is about the rule of
law and people can watch sky news around
the world or read British newspapers and
when they say you seeing things like
that isn't it harder to try and convince
countries like Russia and China in Iran
that they too must obey international we
are where we are a proud nor abiding
country and it is one of the great
glories of the of the UK that we have an
independent judiciary and a legal system
that is Ahmad across the across and
across the planet plus we have the great
advantage of legal certainty and I will
be saying tomorrow everything in a
breakfast I'll be inviting businesses in
America and elsewhere to come to to
London as they have been in ever growing
numbers by the way we've got record in
with investment into our country a
record confidence in the UK because it's
got the rule or it's got the right
language it's got the biggest financial
centre anywhere in in our hemisphere
it's got fantastic advantages so that's
one of the missions that we have here in
in New York today Prime Minister you
talked about the rule of law tomorrow
the Supreme Court will decide whether or
not you were right or wrong to Prague
Parliament if the vote goes against you
you'll be accused of misleading the
Queen you've also gambled and lost in
Parliament do you ever worry that you're
taking risks that are just too big and
this could all topple over making you
the
shortest-lived prime minister in history
I think the most important thing on the
on the case before the Supreme Court
let's wait to see what the justices say
I I do think it was right to and it is
right for us to have a Queen's Speech
we've had the longest period now without
a Queen's beat the longest parliamentary
session since the Civil War
members of the labor front bench have
been clamoring for a Queen's speech to
get on and in the parliamentary session
we finally done it by that and by the
way we're not losing more than four or
five days of parliamentary sitting time
to do this plus don't forget and here's
the kicker actually MPs contrary to what
is suggested MPs will have ample
opportunity to debate brexit and to
study the deal that I may be lucky
enough to do or working to do on October
the 17th and 18th they will have time to
study that to look at the progress of
the negotiations both before that summit
and after but they spent three years
talking about brexit I think the people
of this country aren't exactly
convinced that parliamentarians want to
get brexit done now's the moment for
them to share it on trust there are
questions from your time as mayor of
London you and your office stand accused
of repeatedly doing taxpayer-funded
favors against official advice for a
very close friend of yours Jennifer our
Curie is it true well what I can
certainly say Sam is that we did a huge
amount of work when I was mayor of
London
selling our fantastic city around the
world beating the drum for for London
and indeed for the for the UK I'm very
proud of what we did and I can tell you
absolutely that everything was done with
complete propriety and in in the normal
way look this might be uncomfortable but
it is important what was your
relationship with Jennifer I can tell
you that everything we did to promote
London and the interests of the London
London business was done completely with
in a normal way and we uh Terr propriety
and I'm actually proud now to be doing
the same sort of thing
here in New York promoting our country
promoting our economy and people that
would be in these crowding likely more
people are asking these questions
because they want to know whether they
can trust you not at appearance but to
know whether or not you have integrity
in public office if people can't trust
you at home what a world leaders meant
to make of us as I say we in the nuns
administration did everything with
complete propriety but I think what
world leaders can certainly take from
the UK is that they have an ally and a
partner that will continue to stand by
them we will stand by our friends and
partners in the in NATO in the European
Union and here in the UN and if you look
at what the UK has been able to do here
in in the UN and indeed as we did it
period
we are working to ensure that the West
broadly conceived remains in alignment
on some very very difficult issues
whether that is climate change or what's
happening in the Persian Gulf
biodiversity the UK has a leading role
and I find the the partners I talk to
really value the UK's role they want us
to contribute even more but
is it the case that you just not
answering questions about that
relationship I mean is it because you
used to be a journalist is there a sense
that because with the laws that you that
the Supreme Court are looking whether
you broke or whether questions around
whether or not you used public money
properly is there any sense at all that
the norms and rules don't apply to you
look III I've given you a very clear
answer about my time as as mayor and
what we did to promote London I'm very
proud of that as for what we're doing
here with our friends and partners
around the world you can see were
working hard to promote peace in in that
to stop an escalation in the Gulf region
and if and if you want to promote trust
by the way in politics I never as I
never tire of telling you the single
most important thing you could do
actually is to respect the judgment of
the people and the will of the British
people and to get on and deliver brexit
on October the 31st and that is what
we're going to do last one on brexit and
your policy might be best described as
trying to kick some of the issues around
the Irish border down the road down to
the others of the side of brexit day the
EU seem to be saying no what is there to
talk about here in New York on brexit
given that I think we can make progress
Sam I think it's not easy there are some
very difficult technical issues but
there's a great deal of willingness to
try to make progress I think possibly
what's becoming clear to people is that
the UK has actually made quite a big
offer when it comes to the the unity of
the sanitary and phytosanitary zone for
the whole of Arlen that's a big
concession by us it's an imaginative
move and we're working with our friends
to see how we can develop that thought
and weave consent turn it into a
solution